[Music]
so one of these tunnels leads to the
troll tree that's right so many of them
I wonder which one I don't know
choose a hole yz4 one muli to bergen
town and the others to curtain death
who said that
me hey guys how's it going I just wanted
to warn you one of these tunnels leads
to the troll tree and the others to
certain death death death death death
death do you think you can tell us which
is the right one you bet
great no that's okay we're fine thanks
branch yeah he's trained help us I don't
like the looks of him he seems to know
what he's talking about
ok fine which way do we go first you
have to give me a high five then I'll
tell you I don't do high fives slap it
boss not gonna happen here just do this
but with your hand thank you for that
demonstration really cleared up exactly
what I will not be doing rich it's a
high five the others lead to certain
death get perspective all right
I know let you slide with a fist bump
whoo chug attack no no no no jelly fish
ham sandwich urkki snowman Dolphin
helicopter hot supper monkey the zoo
what gear shift dirt okay okay okay
now I'm thinking we hug
see tons on sent in Magoo Tov
[Music]